so what is your why I mean how many
times you hear somebody asks you a
question what's your why right and we
say well I don't know what my why I
think I'm doing this because I want to
do it from my family or I want to be
financially free and so these questions
ask all the time so many of you message
me and say Pat I want to find out about
my wine what can I do my why what is a
rely what is it so let's define what a
wise first of all anybody watching this
you may not even know it you all have a
why everybody has a wide the challenge
with some people majority peoples why is
it doesn't graduate so your wine needs
to evolve
what is evolved what is evolution of
your why really mean I mean the scene
sounds a little bit too you know a
technical of a topic to say the
evolution of your wine oh simon Sinek
wrote a book it doesn't it all starts
with your why yes it does start with
your why of course it does but a lot of
times we don't get to the next level of
why so today I want to talk to about the
evolution of one and kind of challenge
you on the last level and you'll see
exactly what I'm talking about it with
this so everyone's why goes through the
four phases your first level of why's
what survival
the next mode what I mean by survival
everybody who has a job that makes money
makes money why to survive and pay the
bills but that is there why so unless
you find a way to graduate that then
it's the next level what's the next of
you know I want to make six figures
why status I make six figures I have a
nice car I have a house I have the same
car I'm having a good school I'm going
to a place I got this I got that so it's
status keeping up with the Joneses it's
still lightweight but it's still a
better why than survival the third one
is freedom you know what I'm so sick and
tired of six figures and I want to be
free I want to make money I want to go
out I'm not worried about working hard I
want to make money and I want to have
freedom I want to have breathing room
what do I need to do to have breathing
room that's the next level because then
at that point you're not necessarily
doing it for somebody else you're doing
it because you're wise gradual you know
what I want to be free I want to live in
that community because I want my kids to
play outside and not have to worry about
anything
for me I won't have a big back here
because I want my kids to run or not
have to worry about anything for me for
my family I have
to be free so this is somewhat selfish
nothing wrong with it but it's not the
highest level the highest level is
purpose now what are we talking about
purpose what is your why I'll talk to
some people in the semi why's I want to
one day on a football team is still
empty that's still empty
I want to wander on a basketball team
that people ask me Pat all you want to
know on a sports team of course that's
in the plans if the opportunity comes I
think I'd make a very good sports owner
I'm fascinated by stats sports
improvement competition it's just as
fascinating but is that really the
purpose of making billions of dollars
and making money no there's got to be a
bigger purpose so how does one go from
survival status freedom purpose what is
truly your purpose people ask for that
what's your purpose what is a bigger
picture I can talk about that for an
hour on what my purpose is but I'm
driven by history but that didn't happen
overnight you know the saying goes
sometimes on the way to a dream you get
lost and find a bigger one a bigger
dream you think it was all about the car
you think it was all about the
recognition you think it was all about
the fame you think it was all about the
status you think it was all about
landing that girl you think it's all
about all these other things but it's
much bigger than that then all of a
sudden one day you have a conversation
with somebody or watch a video and watch
a movie or meet someone that just boom
hits you in the face and say wait a
minute what the hell have I been
thinking about I was put on this planet
to do dot dot dot now you're talking
purpose
now you're talking purpose very few
people reach this level why very simple
too lazy to actually spend time thinking
about it
they're afraid what if I could do it and
it'll process the issue well so they
don't take time outs to ask the question
what do you really want to do with your
life you know what do you really want to
do with this you know I'm around a lot
of different people a lot of different
people and I'll sit there and have
conversations you know what I just party
with jay-z last week and jay-z is a
human being you know I just did this and
I just did that I love nice cars because
I love the history and the engineering I
love it I got an arat incentive painting
cure I got things some Ayrton Senna fans
that send me all the time why cuz
I'm fascinated by the guy died on I
think mater in 1994 you know from a race
that he was on sinking May 1st of May
through 1995 the age of 34 years old
after being a three-time champion and he
should have been for time against Prost
and his mom in a clip says I'm just so
proud of my son because he's made us and
you see him trying to wipe his tears and
the day he won the race and spitting in
Brazil oh he had never won in Brazil and
he won the race in Brazil and his
shoulders you gotta pull up his
shoulders and he gets out he's asking
for is that asking for his dad and he
hugs his dad and says that my shoulders
are tight and he doesn't know how to
lift up the ship I mean that's that's
emotional that's exciting to me that's
fascinating to me for a human being to
truly want to find out what's their
maximum capacity where the entire
country was emotional when Senna died I
mean people said we are one of the
poorest countries in the world we have
nothing going on the only thing we have
gone on with Ayrton Senna and other
that's emotional that's purpose I want
to make an impact that's bigger than
that but it only happens if you're
actually willing to sit down and ask
some of the questions the important
questions in life and I think
unfortunately so many times you're just
going going going going going going
going so eventually you don't ask the
important questions in life until it's
your funeral it's already too late and
just so you know about seven billion
people do this every 80 years I suggest
you not be part of the 7 billion you'd
be part of a small community of people
that says you know what maybe I'm not
going to start a company but I'm gonna
be part of the company and you better
believe that company is going to be
impacted because of what I'm going to do
and one day I'm gonna own a piece of
that company that's fine maybe I am
going to be a founder maybe we aren't
going to take the money that I'm making
and I want to go back and teach the
world about entrepreneurship that's what
I'm going to do
last level level number four so as you
process this and go through it again I'm
doing a short video this is not a long
video here you can ask yourself the
question but this is the evolution of
your why and don't you think it's time
for you as you're watching this to have
your why evolve the only thing this
happens is by self-interest you know you
got to go through an inspection of
yourself and one of the things I've
recommended many people to do and use is
the ultimate self-discovery
questionnaire the ultimate
self-discovery question have changed my
life and night it was in 2003 August
where I went to took these 83 questions
completely changed the way I viewed life
I was at the matador beach and I did a
video on this it's on my website you can
find your questions eighty-three
questions Michelangelo let's put it
let's put a link on the bottom matter of
fact let's put the local of the ultimate
self-discovery questionnaire here where
it's out on the website Ilya I can show
you how he does it with a screen zooms
out and then click on a link below if
you don't see any links here which you
can always do is go back to Patrick
Beatty be calm and on Patrick Vader be
calm you will see the link to open
self-discovery question and last but not
least our buddy Mari here just through
the pillow
subscribe to this channel goal is to get
to a hundred thousand subs eventually
we'll be out of million steps we feel
this channel is the best channel for
entrepreneurs and we look forward to
educating instructing and giving the
many entrepreneurs around the world
clarity to take your business to the
next level so if you haven't subscribed
to the channel please click on whatever
the buttons around here changes all the
time of different sites to subscribe to
this YouTube channel thank you everybody
take care
you